let's start becoming familiar with our
parts of speech and we're going to start
with two of the most fundamental ones
first the noun which you will often see
described as a person a place or a thing
and we're also going to talk about verbs
a verb is something that is some type of
action and at first this might seem a
little bit hard to understand what it is
this word now this word verb but as we
do a bunch of examples this will
hopefully make a little bit more sense
so let's first look at this first
sentence bill likes dessert so I
encourage you to pause the video look at
each of these words and say is that a
person place or thing or is it some type
of action or is it neither and so it
would it wouldn't be a noun or verb
let's do it together so in bill likes
dessert bill is a person so it is a
person place or thing so he this the
word bill is a noun so that right over
there bill that is a noun and then bill
likes dessert so likes is not a person
place or thing that would not be a noun
but dessert is a person place or thing
in this case it is a thing so dessert is
also going to be a noun so we have two
nouns we have two nouns in this sentence
bill and dessert but what is likes well
it's the action that bill is taking bill
likes dessert so likes is going to be a
verb or likes is a verb so that is a
verb let's do another example
I slept once again pause the video see
if you can figure out the noun and the
verb all right so we start with I is I a
person place or thing yeah it's a person
it's it's whoever's saying the sentence
in this case I guess it's me so this
would be a noun so let me do that in our
noun color which is going to be yellow
so this is a noun I and then slept is
not a person place or thing it's an
action it's what I did I slept so ah so
slept is a verb
so we had one noun 1 verb let's look at
this next sentence the pretty pig took a
bath once again pause the video and see
if you can identify the person places or
things or the nouns and see if you can
identify any verbs so the pretty pig and
we're gonna cover what the is but the by
itself is not a person place or thing I
used to to kind of get a little ahead
it's called an article and we'll talk
more about that in the future pretty by
itself is not a person place or thing
and it's also not an action so let's
ignore that for now we'll get back to
that but Pig that is a person place or
thing
so pig is a noun pig is a noun and then
took not a person place or thing a not a
person place or thing bath well a bath
is a bath is a thing so that is also now
so those are the nouns right over there
so pig pig and bath now what's our verb
there's one verb in this sentence and
it's what the pig did the action the pig
did the pig took took something it took
a bath so that's our action right over
there that's our verb took is our is our
verb I think we're getting the hang of
this let's keep going the funny bird ran
quickly once again pause the video see
if you can work it out well duh by
itself is not a person place or thing
funny by itself is not a person place of
thing and neither of these are actions
bird is a person place or thing it's a
thing so bird bird is a noun bird is a
noun ran that's what the bird did that's
the action so that's going to be a verb
and quickly is neither an action nor it
is a person place or thing and we'll
study this part of speech in the future
let's look at the sentence he ate the
watch pause the video see if you can
figure out the nouns and the verbs so he
well that's a person so that's going to
be that is going to be a noun eight
that's an action that is going to be a
verb the by itself isn't the person
place or thing but watch is watch is a
thing so that's going to be or
now one more sentence dogs are silly
well dogs are clearly a thing so that's
our now now the verb might might be here
might be a little bit harder to say well
you know is what's the action well the
dogs are silly you can say the action
they are taking is being silly and
that's just just something they do so
this one might be a little bit harder to
understand but what is the dog doing
there they're being silly are is the
action so that right over there that
right over there is the verb so
hopefully this starts to give you a hang
of things and we'll look at a lot more
examples that's really the key of
understanding nouns and verbs and will
also start to think about what all these
other words are that we haven't labeled
yet